[Music]
talk about you know my open-source hobby
of them working for on pi MC 3 and for
those who do not know PI MC 3 is a
Bayesian statistics or probabilistic
programming library in Python we had our
first release and at the start of this
year and releasing software is really
hard I avoid it but fundamentally the
chat that the problem that we're talking
about is Bayesian inference and luckily
I'm the previous talk with tiesm you
know talked a lot about this so you're
busy oh you're famous Bayes theorem I
noticed a lot of tweets going around
yesterday about Bayes is tune when I'm
drunk we may have go on a pilgrimage and
Butler this is the fundamentals
challenge that you're trying to solve so
the traditional approach is Markov chain
Monte Carlo algorithm so I'm going to
talk move about Markov chain Monte Carlo
algorithms which are well studied
arounds it's roughly speaking the 1940s
and I'm going to talk about you know
variational inference and higher your
the strengths and weaknesses of each
approaches or use as a comparison so so
this talks will be quite mathematical
your I've I've declared it as advanced
but I'm going to assume that we have a
quite a confident audience here with
lots of mathematical background so in a
more Christian Maldek level when you
construct a Markov chain whose
stationary distribution is the posterior
distribution you sample from Markov
chain for a long time and you
approximate these posterior quantities
using empirical distribution of the
samples or if you like pictures you can
just you know so you say something like
this so you know this is your posterior
distribution in here you're sampling
from all these file and you're using
that information you know as an
acceptance probability you know to get
to the next spot and this helps you you
approximate your posterior distribution
so let's take like the real simplest
case you know the beta point binomial so
you flip a bunch of coins you observe
for successes and ten trials and we want
to
so you build your numpy array and then
you build your model and for those of
you who are not familiar apply mc3 this
is high we build model to play MC 3 yo
he declared in your context manager or
your with model if you call your model
you know what you're kinda likely to it
is at and and then you size it so this
year is your likelihood function the
other one is your prior function and
then you can like you can even sample
from this you can run a multi Markov
chain Monte Carlo so here here's your
prior see if a uniform prior you're
assuming you know nothing assuming that
both your choices are equally
probabilistic which is a good thing
on this is a weighted coin which is
always a good trick question the task
comin left like Wally has one of its are
weighted coin and and then this is your
posterior solution that you get so like
you know you declare your number of
samples the point of showing the code is
sort of sort of talked through like how
you would actually do this yourself so
you can cool off and you can play with
these things yourself the slides will be
online and you're wrong your your sample
and eelain and we have all this kind of
information about how long this the
sampling process takes and then here's
your finger right so you have your prior
your posterior and this is your MCMC
approximate posterior and you can see
it's not perfect but do it it works
pretty well your this this approximates
this histogram approximates this curve
and there's other things that you can do
you can get like uncertainty
quantification this is just to show some
of the functionality in PI and c3 okay
so that's kind of a very rapid you know
reminder of like your entire graduate
course in statistics you know in less
than five minutes on a Saturday morning
so then he was consuming quite a lot in
the audience here but these are kind of
like so I'm assuming that people have
played around these things or they are
at least aware but these are like the
pros there are rigorous mathematical
reasons why you would use NC NC
is syntactically unbiased right so you
can prove mathematically this
convergence to the true posterior the
problem is it might take a really long
time I had a MCMC problem last year that
took like three days to converge which
was assigned to my model was bad but
like I just left it on the weekend came
back every wife is still running um you
have model agnostic algorithm so you
don't really care about what your model
is it could be a plus on distribution it
could be something like the Bayesian
optimization approach that we saw
earlier on I'm various other things and
that's the other very important point
well studied for sixty years the other
protein language you are a lot newer and
one of the problems of things that are a
lot newer is that the kinks have not
been quite you know examined yet so you
know like you should always think how
long you know how much of a mathematical
history or your approach has so here's
the cons you know you can take a long
time to converge you don't have any good
metrics for assessing convergence so you
know you you can examine things but it's
not like you can like say it hits this
point you know you know youth converts
and the probably the bigger problem of
these models is that they're difficult
to scale so often like um Michael
Bennett Cory's one of the stand and
standard domain specific language for
Bayesian statistics as well you know I'm
sort of a competitive project IMG three
or family competitive progress project
and but he says like you know awesome
big data means simple models so if you
scale up to like a large data set you're
often using something quite conceptually
simple like logistic regression so you
know how do we scale with more
complicated models to bigger data and
this kind of less here
approach a question or scalability
problem is one leads us to you
variational inference what we will talk
about later on does anyone have any
questions so far you two free to like
jump in or like yoga make this a bit
more interactive
this is the Jupiter load vocalist in
your in your github is it an advanced PI
mc3 talk the friend coil is Mike idiom
yes by that alone the tutorial or now
BAM toriel i regularly freak at these
events so there's a few things and it's
in advance ing three talk okay okay so
so this is the variational inference and
as you can see that there is going to be
math so all the table masters in this
stuff and so variation influence you
choose a class of approximating
distributions and you're looking to find
the best approximation of the true
posterior you're not finding the true
posterior it's a purely approximate
method right so that's not a little
thing so unlike MCMC where i could tell
you you you'll get the true posterior
this will find an approximate best
answer we will see an example the inter
visualizes to talk about that you know
to make this thing a bit easier but
that's kind of like the caveat the kind
of a trade-off that you take on for
better scalability and you open up a new
class of problems that you wouldn't be
able to lock up but approximations okay
we regularly do it you know we're all
not always interested in the
mathematically rigorous best answer
we're sometimes interested in you know
an answer at all so for those of you
know a bit of information theory or
something like this you know if you
don't know this just consider this here
you know you know a difference between
two objects that you're trying to
minimize you know so that means that you
actually got an optimization problem so
we talked about the step where we'll see
a few visual examples but this is what
we're trying to minimize that cool back
live ler diversions as I said those
names wrong I'm very sorry I'm and you
can prove that minimizing there's a cool
back live Lloyd divergence is equivalent
to maximizing the
evidence lower barn so if you look at
your like your your your rigorous
definition of them you're a Bayesian
integral you'll see on the bottom you'll
have an evidence and that's like the
thing that you're actually trying to you
know you know compute at you know
analytically and you have this here like
constant term but we're mathematicians
we don't care about the constant terms
we just pretend it doesn't exist so so
this is an example and this comes from
some of the other contributors to times
III so you have been borrowing a lot of
different examples here Austin Rockford
and Taku Yoshioka so here's a true
distribution so this is a Gaussian
distribution of some description this is
what we we know is our we're going to
assume that we know is our posterior and
we're going to approximate this true
distribution using you know a diagonal
conversions Gaussian from this class
there are many ways to variational
inference this is one of the most common
one and this is used in PI MC 3 as one
of their classes there's a lot of
research particularly they like to
deepmind
of like you know opt you know coming up
with better ways to optimize you know
you know to optimize our KL divergence
but here so here you have a variation
approximation so this is not the same as
this right these are different right but
difference is the KL divergence but this
is not that this is reasonably
approximate right and so like by you
know changing the kernel that you're
using your your your Gaussian covariance
matrix you might be able to stretch this
out or something like that so this is
like the trade-off that you're taking
mod so you're not getting a true answer
like a rigorous mathematical answer of
this but you're getting an approximation
so we have a load of pros and we're
going to talk about this Philip you
trade complexity so you trade comp like
algorithmic time complexity so you've
given that up you know you've you've
reduced your time you know but you're
taking on bias right so you've got a
bias your estimate of your maximum
likelihood estimation here you can use
optimization Theory optimization theory
is a well rigor you know research area
you know since you you know for maybe
like 100 years but certainly since the
Second World War we have a lot of tools
they're they scale well with our modern
hardware you can use things like
stochastic gradient descent all these
things work very well
you have assessment of convergence so
you can you'll see this in one of the
examples I think or or certainly on like
github but there are you know you can
like you can prove that something has
converged you can say that's a good
enough answer you know take that answer
which means is you don't need to leave
something on going for three days you
know if it works in 30 minutes it works
in 30 minutes and you got like you know
principles and scalable approach from
out model selection a bit like earlier
on we were talking a model selection and
Bayesian optimization there's more
approach and if you've transformed the
problem of integration or a problem
sampling to one of optimization
you've got numerical stability you get
convergence it works for you know almost
all probabilistic models it works well
in modern day computing architectures
CPUs and GPUs I don't think any of it
works yet with GPUs in PI and z3 and
pull requests are welcome and then you
have a compact representation of your of
your posterior distribution so lots of
probes you can see I'm very biased apart
my locus of this algorithmic class cons
texts typically underestimate the
variance of the posterior and can bias
maximum likelihood parameter estimates
it's better for prediction than
interpretation so you can get a good
answer but like you you don't have the
same interpret ability
you would have in like a traditional
Bayesian approach when you really
understand every step of of the process
here during you understand how your
priors right you understand how your
samplers worked it can give stock in
local optima here so although it's
optimization problem you know if it's a
non-convex pace which you assume those
spaces are you're going to get stuck on
the co optima and malo specific
algorithms that's one of the pros to the
problems of implementing these things
there's a lot of research in this area
and this could limited Theory fit back
to what I said earlier on has not been
studied for sixty years the first paper
and variational inference I think stuck
was on late 80s maybe early 90s there's
been a lot of work in the last like five
six years um
but yo it still doesn't have the
rigorous you like statistical approval
but I know that more pragmatic than I'd
already care but um but like these are
kind of like things so so the reason I
emphasize the the cons are you know when
you're picking a message if it's only
one thing you take from this call but
when you're picking a new method
particularly something that's like not
well researched you need to understand
the trade-offs that you are taking
whenever you use this method right so
you know speed and I'm kind of getting
rid of out you know time complexity is
really important if you're working for a
software as-a-service startled um or
anywhere else you'll finance whatever
but you are taking on bias like you're
you're you're you're you're taking on
that not that's a trade off and that's
fine right sometimes that is the right
choice to make and no method is a free
lunch you know like you pick a message
for you know because of strengths and
weaknesses of the problem that you're
applying approach so that's kind of like
you know the kind of like the reminder
of why you would use this thing if it
allows you to scale probably signal to
increase the complex problems and and
one of the methods that Artie
implemented in mini-batch so so advi is
automatic differentiation variational
inference in my slides I have a rigorous
explanation of what all that means
ignore all that it's just highly the
very
inference Empires III and house
different or you're different you know
if in the key words okay Arabic their
arguments of the function of one of the
functions you know you can take
different methods and there are
strengths and weaknesses to that what I
find is that like just trust the one
that really works out of the box you
know if it works great if it doesn't use
a different methods like it is quite an
empirical approach that because as I
said all these things are not really
theoretically supported yet and many
parts advi Elijah just scaled a larger
data set I was always one of the
criticisms of Bayesian models what you
know one of the the other not entirely
true but not entirely wrong statement
with a Bayesian models we work with
small dinner for many by JD gray allows
you to scale up and we should see an
example before the end of the talk so
can three good use cases for this large
scale couple topic modeling and I have a
topic modeling example in my in my
notebooks whether online I'm not going
to give that example because it's not
very good but um the other other
approaches Dale the air seem to work a
lot much better and semi supervised
classification there's a lot of research
on this as you know so one of the
problems that you have with any machine
learning problem is lack of labels you
know so semi supervised classification
is very interesting and this uses a lot
of these approaches and I hypothesize
that the generative models for for
images which is also another use case of
this you know the various implements are
using this space if use a lot of the you
know the deep deep learn these low and
deep learning work particularly like to
Google etc you can see the papers coming
out of them or the archives so so
there's kind of like there's that
objection that we've already like talk
to Python so unlike MCMC you know we're
unable to cover the tree distribution if
you remember my picture but earlier on
here we've got a variational
approximation but it wasn't true
posterior distribution
there's loads of research on resolving
this problem right because like these
methods are really promising right you
know you scale though they all these
sort of things you're allowing you to
open up a new class of problems that you
wouldn't be able to do with like Markov
chain Monte Carlo methods so people are
trying to attack that the under trend
still and there's great paper by Shakira
Mohammed
at all of deepmind when they talk about
the embed Norma is closed
I mean we're still in the process of
reviewing that at times III I think it
should go in in the next couple of
months but like this shows you like hi
sir sir cutting edge some parts of the
library or themselves because like the
paper and this is like a year old so you
know the papers a year old
sorry implemented there's stuff with sex
month so that's already like being
talked about as I in there so this is
there is a discussion of that in our
notebook but I won't be talking about
this book I just want to tell you like
you know although the statistician in me
is offended that these methods aren't
perfect you know like you know they
don't have that rigorous CIO
resolve of the true posterior
distribution you know there is hope
there I which is a good example of why
it's so exciting to be you know Bayesian
you're like there's all this interesting
work happening so I'm not going to talk
too much about this and but in Edward
which is another library which is really
good library based on tensorflow
PI and XIII's based on piano and in
Edward they use black box variation
inference tensor libraries are really
useful because they allow you to compute
gradients automatically that's pretty
much the whole algorithmic gradient
approach that you're trying to do and
Plan C 3 a DVI
and there is math but we're not going to
go into that so um primarily because
it's not a great medium the best medium
is to sit and work through it yourself
if you're so interested if you're just a
pragmatic and you just want to know how
you use this how you leave this talk
like as something that you can use in
your work on Monday morning and then
deal that's kind of like what I'm aiming
for the rest of this so this is quite
restrictive criteria differentiable
probability models but a lot of
probability models are just distributed
there's a differentiable and you
approximate you know there's a
transformation step we go to a different
parameter space and then you you
approximate posterior with a mean field
Gaussian which is very similar to the to
the guiding covariance matrix that you
saw earlier on your corny like over a
bigger a few more parameters so this
work is based by Thomas tacky who's a
maintainer of time c3 and a good friend
of mine I hated busy and neural networks
in PI MC 3 I win bingo um with that one
so why would you want to do busy and
neural networks right so one of the
fundamental limitations of deep learning
methods is we don't understand really
how they work right they are blackbox
machine learning models they are
tremendously powerful like as you can
see with the entire investment in the
self-driving car community and in the
examples like image net in 2012 of Emmys
recognition with this approach you get
to things that are quite interesting
you're getting certainty in predictions
they inform us about you know the
uncertainty in the prediction we're
getting you'll see this towards the end
of the talk and you get in certain date
in our representations so we also get a
certainly estimate of our weights which
tells you some a disabilities which we
can use to inform the weights that we
choose
so let's generate some toy data we're
going to do a simple binary
classification problem that's not
linearly separable
thanks a psychic learn you get this so
you have class zero exhaust one so we're
going to do a really simple neural
network and so perceptron which is
nothing more just like regression the
original implementation of this I think
a slightly different number of layers
I've used three hidden layers with six
neurons each and the original
implementation I think had to head in
layers and five neurons it doesn't make
a huge difference I think it does turn
out that if you do like 20 in your
twenty head layers its ceaseless if your
accuracy drops down really low so the
only so we can like construct so like
you know so because this is PI mc3 or
like we have to define our piano floats
and we just have our we just hit come
here like so article life actually five
hidden layers I've changed the code or
not the writing and that's a problem
with working on this in the morning um
so you initialize your your random way
to a Slayer and you use PI MC 3 to have
like a normal distribution on it on each
layer here and then like your infer from
that so this simple neural network with
a bit of PI and C 3 in there so so this
isn't so bad
so the normal priors help us regularize
the weight so it's a regularization
method and we're going to use a maxing
one of the contributors is so productive
that like in the space of giving this
talk about three months ago he ended up
doing entirely different methods you
know of European TV I based on a paper
by David
I and Dustin Trani of Columbia
University and operated various an
inference which has some overcome some
of the variance problems I highlighted
an industry end and variational
influence in general so we're going to
use that method because this is brand
new so so if you're not really familiar
with this I wouldn't worry too much it
was like a little trick here about U of
M I love this cost part grade scale and
this just reduces the variance lots of
kind of thing that we're trying to
reduce here so you know we just liked
all fit model you call this inference
method you know it's quite simple API
okay so if you're five minutes um and it
works pretty well on my computer on a
standard like Apple Mac so you can do no
grad scaling and use the old interface
to about thirty seconds so let's look at
what we actually got so there
unfortunately is not a huge difference
with that there no scaling versus the
new adv I was a bit surprising I wasn't
able to figure out why that was and
theoretically you should get your
performance improvements but one of the
advantages of showing your work is you
see that not everything works as
perfectly as you can imagine and that's
just something you have to take um and
you know so we actually got like a
difference that I do diagnostics check
it's not to worry too much about this
let's actually look at one of the
advantages of Bayesian statistics we can
look at the posterior predictive check
so with your predicted labels you can
see that very similar to what we had in
the previous in the earlier slide and
our testing set accuracies 92.2% that's
not bad you know not quite good enough
to your self-driving car
Biagio it's only it's a very simple
secure Network and so the the next
slides are going to show you our stuff
that you wouldn't get in other methods
so you you can look at our probability
surface it's also you would see this in
an another method so you look at our
Paulo the leaf surface you can see that
we're going to have like we seem to have
some indication that is but more
uncertainty around the decision boundary
we can actually do a little bit more
than this
not just this this is more a traditional
machine learning approach we can
actually look at the standard deviation
of the posterior predictive to get a
sense of the uncertainty are in our
predictions and here's what that looks
like so you can see that like the darker
colors indicate a higher uncertainty and
you can see that around our decision
boundary we have a higher uncertainty so
one of the things thomas was saying to
me was that like you could actually use
that to like aim your network right so
train more sample more on those highly
uncertain parts because that's the parts
you actually want to solve in the same
way like in the gaussian process thing
you want to like explore the area that
you know is most promising or that you
need more information about it so let me
say this now one of the reasons i think
this is really important is that
interprete Balai explainable models are
going to become more and more important
you know protected we're going to have
regulatory change with gdp are coming in
soon you know but you're going to see
like a lot more need for these kind of
interpret models so um you can also
scale this aside I'm not going to
because we're getting towards the end
and it's time to wrap up you can see
this in my slides all I did was I just
scaled it to a bigger data set and I
started to use that method and I'm going
to wrap that up at this point if
everyone's okay with that and I hope
that was an interesting
nation or higher you can actually do
busy and deep learning and I'd love to
see anyone comes up with you know in
terms of like hi this could be a prior
to another problem because it's really
interesting and promising research area
any questions there's someone there I
say a higher if you're adding more
layers if you have a very deep network
or if yes something complex like an SPM
intuitively a lot of things in these
networks tend to blow up so do you still
get useful in certainties out the end of
the bigger network like that or do they
end up getting too big to be useful
after that point or I haven't done
enough highly complicated networks to
comment and every reckless to speculate
I think I like you know I think more
examples like you there haven't been
many papers or examples like this you
know or blog post published so I'm sure
people are using it I'm sure there's
like there's parts of reading of Google
research which are like you're looking
at these things um I try it yourself and
let me know some days there with thanks
hi there I'm really interesting talk I'm
curious could you give a little more
detail around how this helps with model
explained ability I didn't quite make
that connection in my um I mean like so
like these kind of plots right you allow
you you know say more bite on certain
day you know so you know like you can
just say that this here is a more
uncertain area and that I think gives
you more than like the original plot
which like just care tells you this is
predicted and this isn't predictive it
doesn't tell you anything about the
uncertainty of those predictions so the
defense that I was saying at the start
was that having uncertainty in your
predictions you know you know gives you
more information that you wouldn't get
in a traditional deep learning approach
I hope that's a satisfactory answer yeah
I think so I mean I I think you still
end up with a sort of black box
situation where it's not
Claire why predictor is making the
prediction it is yeah
but saying that a component of a system
is on more uncertain than another
component is more information you know
yeah that's I guess auditability is more
a better word than then explained
ability sure thank you thank you very
much for the talk on the Bison neural
Nets a point that you mentioned could
you explain if variational inference
could be used to UM use this kind of
neural net to optimize their the sample
space used in reinforcement learning
would that make application with
relation inference that's a good
question and that does scientific
research paper I'm sure I could and I I
don't know of any literature and that
that lots of that I I'm not really
well-versed with the robotics community
or reinforcement learning community but
and perhaps I would have a go and let me
know
hi there and just just more of a comment
to the gentleman over there there is a
paper - Ali - evil ads at Harvard Plus
collaborators where she uses a form of
black box variational inference to do
deep reinforcement learning basically
model based deep reinforcement learning
where the model is a transition function
that tries to learn the probability of
transition between states and they used
a Bayesian neural network for that it
was very useful because the uncertainty
in the Bayesian neural network could be
used profitably in situations where you
can't exploit the space of actions so
the example given was a gas turbine you
can't exploit the space of possible gas
turbine actions that in a live gas
turbine because you could obviously
damage it so you have to very high
uncertainty estimates about your next
state yeah I'm actually just in foot for
the other gentleman over there on I'm
giving a talk tomorrow actually on
Bayesian deep learning yeah using
Edwards so I have a small amount of
experience on training for slightly
larger networks at least my very
preliminary results are the mean field
assumption in variational inference can
become a little bit problematic I
haven't done very deep networks but I've
done wider networks and I found that
actually if you actually make them
narrower you get better results well I
look forward to your talk
yeah you're to wait for their like hi
powder thanks the plot you've got up at
the moment and the the other one with
with the uncertainties on it presumably
the coloring on the point is that
predicted classes from the look of it
yeah yeah yeah yeah I guess I was
expecting to see the the misclassified
points as well have you got the plots or
can you easily get the plot that shows
us which points are correct and which
ones are not
I'm sure you can I don't think I had
that I don't think I did no one I think
it's quite easy to recover from you know
the for the mess you're talking with
your false negatives in your false
policy yeah and you quoted the ninety
two percent or whatever but I guess when
I'm looking at this site you know I
would have assumed that maybe the white
things around big you us but all the
things in the pale Reds of you know
breaks in the red class and all things
in the light blues and yeah bricks in
the blue cloth so I'd really like to
have seen the the true classification
here the an understanding of yeah I mean
okay this is what the models saying good
yeah what's the reality I guess I was
just a bit confused and yeah I think
that's quite easy to reveal so I could
try to cook something up and yeah okay
thank you and there's one last question
that's what happily yet because I think
somewhere else has to speak so you
mentioned the audit ability of your
final fitted distribution so I was
wondering the often okay can you get a
indication of how much the buyers that
you introduced is by making the
assumptions that you do in variational
inference so because the final
distribution is biased but do we know
how biased it is is that is that a
metric is there a metric for getting a
patent yeah there are there are methods
or not and I think we have them
implemented as well like in terms of
like in do model selection these things
like WIC which is a traditional Bayesian
you know approach and there's
there's other ones too yeah there's
model flexion is an entire different
talk that's you we could talk about yeah
okay
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]